how does it feel being back good I had
such good memories here maybe my happy
place can be our happy place who left
you all alone down
here
imagin I'm playing a new game with chy
the scavenger hunt list that's fun chy
says you're not allowed to play with us
oh because you left him I need something
happy something
happy G I thought bugs freaked you out
if I can finish my list tranty will take
me on a trip to the place he's
[Music]
from something that hurts
Alice you've been spending time with a
new
friend he asked you to do something
think that hurt you that was part of the
game does that seem like a game a good
friend would want to play maybe we
shouldn't play together anymore chy
maybe we shouldn't be friends no no no
no Alice Alice Alice Alice Alice
Alice she's lost but we're going to find
her was just
IM every culture has entities that
tether to the young we call them
imaginary
friends you are always playing with your
imaginary friend when the connection was
severed The Entity becomes
inrage he says he's right behind
you but just
imagin can I hang out with your
imaginary friend he's not
imaginary he's not your
[Applause]
[Music]
friend